we have some good vibes for you anthony
anderson has officially graduated from
howard university yes congrats to the 51
year old who took over instagram on the
weekend to share the exciting news that
he graduated with a bachelor of fine
arts degree writing a part on instagram
to quote biggie it was all a dream words
can't begin to describe the emotional
rollercoaster i'm on right now it's
literally been 30 years in the making
this is just the beginning yes also in
attendance at the graduation ceremony
was taraji p henson who gave a stirring
commencement speech at her alma mater
alma mater on the film yep where she
also received an honorary doctorate
bye everyone
alma mater howard
i challenge you to look for the good in
yourself the joy in the world every day
how would i challenge you to look for
the good in others
to offer grace to others because you
know they are fighting a battle just
like you
howard i challenge you to take care of
yourself mentally and emotionally as
well as physically because you look too
good on the outside to not be doing the
work on the inside
thank you
how would i challenge you to keep the
little child within you alive and
thriving give them room and space to
play
i challenge you to listen to that voice
within yourself the one that's separate
from instagram twitter cable news and
the latest gossip and reality tv the
voice that just yours that's just yours
the voice that's there in your quiet
moments when no one else is around
that's your instinct
that's your discernment that's your god
voice train yourself to hear it listen
to it will you do that for me please